i made a whole lot of enemies
tracksuit mafia
even the black widow that doesn't sound
good this holiday season tell the boss
christmas came early
hawkeye
is on everyone's list
[Music]
hi
i'm here to kill him
clint barton
we need a ton of triggers
marvel studios hawkeye only on disney
plus ready
this holiday season fun doesn't get any
bigger than hawkeye
that's amazing and the biggest surprises
are yet
to come
hawkeye only on disney plus
hawkeye and i are working on a case uh
and we needed to use the bathroom i he
reheated so we were by the house and we
dropped in no big deal working on a copy
terrific
he's my partner
we're not partners or
friends slash partners i wouldn't really
describe us as friends
someone used my laptop to sign out of my
work account 10 minutes ago any thoughts
kate
hawkeye
oh you'll he'll never get anything out
of him
see cb1 has trouble opening up yeah
nobody calls me cb1 i'm just trying to
know for a second probably some early
childhood
thing he thinks he doesn't tell me much
but he ends up kind of virtually tell
her nothing um but yeah i think it's
cause i'm generally just pretty chill
you know i'm not like oh my god hawkeye
definitely not joe
by the way thank you
for saving the world
don't mention it
you